there is something profound about the
innocence of a child and to the
untrained eye
scp-053 seems like an adorable little
three-year-old girl the epitome of
innocence however just being too close
to her can be incredibly dangerous as
being in her presence for longer than 10
minutes will provoke paranoia and
homicidal urges in anyone over the age
of three eventually those affected will
begin to act on those urges killing
everyone around them and then attacking
the little girl however attempts to
physically harm her will cause the
attacker to die immediately scp-053 will
regenerate instantaneously from any
physical damage done to her regardless
of severity and will appear wholly
ignorant to the experience surprisingly
when introduced to scp-682 she had the
complete opposite effect on her new
playmate her being around 682 made the
beast shockingly docile causing it to
calm down and allowing her to play with
it but of course it immediately started
killing people again as soon as she left
how rude